jj1 the Texans defensive been joining us
on the program how are you today are you
doing I'm doing okay
how much football did you watch last
night most of the first half was a wild
game he said a good game I mean I woke
up this morning everything I read said
it was like one of the best games of all
time so yeah I would imagine it was look
it is can we have too much little
exploring yeah I'm a defensive guy so of
course my answer is yes but I mean a
couple of those touchdowns around
defensive s off on the highlights as
more in there's a pick six I mean
obviously the fumble for a touchdown so
can it should be them all to offense but
I mean I know it's I I get it I mean
it's people want to want to scoring so I
understand it but obviously the
defensive guy it you want to see a
little bit more defensive scoring but I
liked last night but was there a
significant rule change or is it just
been a series of rule changes in the
last couple of years that have kind of
opened this up where it feels like it's
big 12 football yeah I mean I definitely
think it's been a little bit gradual
over the years I mean I think you know
I've always said that probably the
hardest position besides quarterback out
there to play in the NFL is defensive
back I mean you can't really touch
anybody after five yards you know you
can't make any contact whatsoever it's
and you have to basically run with a guy
running full-speed and he knows where
he's going you don't know where he's
going and you're trying to find a way to
make a plan I mean that's that's
extremely difficult to do and so I've
always said that's tough and I'm sure
that's obviously helped distribute to
the offensive points a little bit would
you rather face a predominantly running
team or predominantly passing team I
love to rush the passer so I always know
I'd like to say some passing team but
it's easier to know which they're gonna
get I would say against the running team
what changed with this team after the
slow start now all of a sudden the
Texans are you know a playoff caliber
team
not a ton not a time we just started to
find a way to finish a game I mean it
wasn't like there was one miraculous
moment where all of a sudden or like how
we should be winning instead of losing
we just we just went to work every day
and little things it was just little
things well there was penalties or
whether it was winning the turnover
ballarino stuff like that but then we
believed in each other now I mean we
believe we're gonna find a way to win
and even if you look at our last couple
games I mean
they haven't been the most pretty games
in the world and we went to a couple
overtime games early in this streak but
we believed we were gonna find a way to
win at the end of the game we had no
idea how the last two games it just
happened to be we needed them to miss a
field goal on the last play of the game
and got away yeah you beat the Redskins
23 21 you're now seven and three first
in the AFC South you had the injury with
Alex Smith you were involved in that
tackle when did you know it was serious
you know he had to play you know it was
third down so we were off the field so I
went back over the sidelines and I got
back over there I saw him down so I I
took a knee and I thought it was like a
head injury or something - I saw so many
people around him he had really moved a
lot and then one of our trainers walked
over to me and said he broke his leg and
I mean that's that's tough to hear I
mean I personally spoke my leg on the
field last year in a game against Alex
Smith so unfortunately I have a at least
a little bit of a basis to know kind of
what he's feeling at that moment and
it's just I mean it's the worst I mean
you don't want anybody ever to have to
go through something like that I just I
felt sick and terrible what is that
feeling though when you break your leg
it's not good it's not good
are you in shock
I didn't know it was broken so I was
mine I thought it was probably just an
ACL or something cuz I heard a snap a
pop but I assumed it was my ACL
so they came out I did the ACL test
and which is just moving your knee
around move your leg around and then we
went I tried to walk off and that's
helped a little weird so we went over to
the tent and the doctor was moving it
around a little bit more trying to
figure out exactly what was wrong and
there's a lot of stuff kind of crackling
around in there and then we went into
the x-ray room and find out it was
broken so I made a little bit more sense
why I hurt so bad
he's JJ Watt the Texans defensive end
he'll certainly be on the shortlist for
Defensive Player of the Year ten sacks
already this season we were wondering if
the future of the pass rusher is is it
more up the middle now with Aaron Donald
or is it still going to be on the edge
in your opinion I think it can be either
I think obviously you have a guy a
Terrence caliper I mean up the middle is
in the sector I don't think that we can
say he's normal by any means he's an
incredible pass rusher but I think that
you know especially with God is being
able to chip on the edges and double
teams are bringing a tight end or
something in you can tend to find a way
up the middle and obviously it's a
quicker path if you can get there clean
I mean it's just point A to point B is a
little bit quicker but like I said it
takes a guy of a very high caliber to be
able to do it the way he's daughter how
do you feel when you want your brother
play more brothers yeah extremely proud
I mean it's nervous it's the coolest
thing in the world
no not nervous but it's like I'm
watching my own like myself play like
it's like you're you live in every play
like I can every single password for TJ
I'm like turn the corn turn the corn
come on hit the ball like I I want the
quarterback to hold the ball I wanted to
you know I want to strip sack and every
time I watch it Derek I'm living the
block with him room last game you had a
feel for like nine yards and I got
called back and I was like pissed off
the guy got called back on you know I
think it says you live it with them and
it's it's the coolest thing in the world
to be able to watch an NFL game and have
a brother out there yeah I don't know
what it's like for your parents when
they watch they probably watch it
differently than you do
yeah so they are every week they're
generally on the road every single they
don't go home during football season so
they're eclair at one of our games every
week select this week they were not
Jacksonville for TJ's game and I was at
the same time so Gatorade has been
awesome them sweet said pretty much
every single stadium in the Emily so
they they give my family a suite and all
our way games so they have a suite and
they're watching TJ on the field in my
game on the TV and my dad was telling me
something that was interesting and I
didn't even think about he was like so
we can watch the bowls he said but both
teams kicked off first this game so you
were both on the field at the exact same
time so it's has a tough dilemma for
them but they're always watching you
know which quarterback you sank the most
in your career I think it's it's
probably the locker
maybe luck yeah you got him ten times is
it playing twice a year that's an unfair
advantage Blake bortles is second on
that list okay
the Colts are a little bit different
than Andrew Luck is you know they not
giving up sacks and he's Comeback Player
of the Year I don't know you're gonna be
up for a comeback player of the year
with you and lock in there oh you've got
an incredible job I mean I mean what
they've been able to accomplish and
obviously as he goes on to get stronger
he continues to get stronger he's a
great player and I think that we all
knew that if you could get healthy I'm
you know myself the same way after the
last couple years he would be back to
playing the way that he knew he could
and he's been able to do that he makes
quick decisions to get the ball out
quick he's he's a great player
it's Thursday gonna be a cheat day yes
cooking up so I believe I saw my dad
sneaking with some pot before and he's
been known to they put the pie before
the Thanksgiving Day anyway so I have to
make sure it stays out before we get to
Thursday could you take out a full
Turkey yourself I wouldn't pick the
turkey to be the thing I fully take out
on the Thanksgiving table I think it
would definitely be the pie
or possibly the mashed potatoes and
gravy well Happy Thanksgiving to you and
congrats so far on the season good luck
against the Titans and always appreciate
your time thank you guys have a great
day that's ojj want Texans defensive n
they'll be up for Comeback Player of the
Year more importantly for him Defensive
Player of the Year he's already won at
three times four more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]